(bright music)
- [Narrator] Some 600
miles east of Moscow,
a new facility in the town of Yelabuga
is getting ready to ramp up
Russia's production of drones.
The White House says the plants
will manufacture Iranian drones
with operations starting
as soon as early 2024.
(drone buzzing)
Russia's invasion of Ukraine showed
how inexpensive unmanned aerial vehicles
or UAVs were effective
on the battlefield for
reconnaissance and for attacks.
Aviation experts say, unlike Ukraine,
Russia's use of unmanned
systems got off to a slow start.
Here's how Moscow is
catching up in the drone race
by building up arsenals of
low-cost explosive drones.
(airplane jet revving)
Early in the war,
Russia mostly relied on
conventional military UAVs.
Reconnaissance drones like
this orlan have been effective
as spotting targets and
calling in artillery fire.
But these systems are
relatively expensive,
costing around $100,000 a unit,
and military experts with CNA
and American Defense Research Organization
believe Russian forces had a
limited number of these UAVs
with plans to significantly
ramp up production in 2023.
(air whooshing)
Meanwhile, Ukrainian
troops started using cheap,
modified commercial
drones for surveillance
and to destroy valuable
Russian equipment early on.
As the invasion turned
into a war of attrition,
Moscow realized its need for
low-cost explosive drones.
In mid 2022, Moscow started
importing Iranian shahed drones
to targets Ukrainian infrastructure.
CNA expert, Samuel Bendett,
estimated the price tag
for the shaheds to be under $50,000 each,
which makes it cost-effective
for Russia to use.
And with this new plant,
Russia will be able
to produce some 6,000 Iranian
design drones on its territory
in the coming years,
according to officials
from a country aligned with the US.
(tense music)
But shahed can only navigate
to pre-programmed targets.
(drone thudding)
So in response to Ukraine's
counter offensive,
Russia has been increasingly
using domestically-produced lancet drones,
which are flown by pilots in real time.
(worker speaking in Russian)
- [Narrator] In July,
Russian state media reported
from what it said was a former
shopping mall that was turned
into a plans to assemble lancets.
Russia's defense ministry
has increasingly reported
on the small UAVs damaging
Ukrainian weapons,
including arms supplied by the West.
(Vladimir Putin speaking in Russian)
- [Narrator] In August,
Vladimir Putin asked
for the production of lancets to increase.
It's not clear how many of
these drones Russia has.
Last October,
Russian pro-war bloggers put
the number at 1,500 units.
(calm music)
Kiev has acknowledged the challenges posed
by Russian drones such
as lancets and orlans
to its forces on the battlefield.
The Ukrainian government
says the vehicles rely
on foreign made parts, some
imported from the West.
The chief of staff to the
Ukrainian presidents call
for more sanctions on
Russian drone producers
and stricter controls
over components' exports.
Military experts agree
that sourcing components is a major issue
for the Russian drone industry.
But if Russia still
manages to quickly ramp
up production of low-cost drones,
this could spell trouble
for Ukrainian forces.
(air whooshing)
(calm music)